life isn't always as peaceful as it
seems
there might not be any obvious signs of
war
but the very nature of warfare is
changing
and attacks from states like russia and
china can come in many other forms
defence chiefs predict peril if these
greyzone threats are ignored
so on the one hand we might wake up one
day and discover that we are in a police
state
and all of our freedoms have been denied
us that's one end of it
the other end of it is that our
opponents will have found a way to
unravel our democracy from inside and
our
freedom our way of life and all the
things that we aspires
would have been undermined and we won't
have noticed it without a shot being
fired
that that successful gray zone warfare
from
adversaries and they will have done it
using proxies
done it through cyber done it through
crippling an economy
and then if you did want to drive in one
day with your armor brigade there's not
much left
to get in the way the uk's former
national security adviser
also warns about a range of threats that
sit in this gray zone between war
and peace the danger is that
by the time we notice that the damage
has been done it
is too late to address it
because this is the nature of the
grazing think of the gray zone as a
global battlefield where anyone
anywhere can be a target weapons of
choice
include disinformation spread online to
influence mimes
and cyber hacks the gray zone has many
physical dimensions too
from assassinations and intimidation
to threatening to cut off a country's
access to oil and gas
or infiltrating critical supply chains
when you start to think of all the
different ways nations can hurt each
other short of war
the options are literally endless
[Music]
now online is a new front line attacks
can come
anywhere there's internet no matter how
remote
this investigator exposes fake news
designed to undermine democracies
but often comes under fire himself it
can become very personal
when you start getting the death threats
when you start getting
the really really personal attacks it
actually means that you've done a good
job
because you have said something you have
exposed something
which is so important to them that they
are trying to either silence you or
discredit you
he's not backing down but the gray zone
isn't going away either and it's a
threat to everyone
debra haynes sky news